you're getting it
I'm trying you got there by the tree so
for the honey okay
never in my wildest dreams did I think
I'd be here
our second day of 4x4 Jeep Eng just
trying to get a few styling shots
my first assignment so it's a lot of
pressure it's good to get warmed up
we're here for National Geographic to
get the shot of Maui the last hunter of
a hallucinogenic honey moly done on your
enamel we did God is uh one of mothers
here it'll be a 15 mile trek into a
remote camp to get to the first honey
harvesting cliff but first it's
mandatory to appease Ron chemi the
forest spirit who wrote grant us safe
passage on all the dangerous tasks ahead
are you guys ready up top oh sorry
sure pop Ibanez Miami's r2s Massa Massa
Medina yes my bondo Portuguese semester
semester China nut okay we're clear got
the clip for Hut I'm going down into
space
pretty full-on down here
you believe this
the size of the hive is ridiculous
you get a pair done I'm getting strong
through the suit
Wow I think that could have been the
shot
you